a highly divisive issue in bolivia the
trial of former interim president
janinas
she's been in pre-trial detention for
almost a year and could be sentenced up
to 12 years if she's found guilty of the
charges of unconstitutionally assuming
the presidency following the removal of
evo morales in 2019
even though the trial was suspended at
last minute outside the courthouse her
supporters say the trial is a sign of
revenge by the current administration of
louis sarase
she has to be freed because what is
happening to her is unfair eva morales
and his followers are seeking revenge
with this woman but she is not alone she
is with us and we will defend her but
not everyone agrees government
supporters say anyas has to be tried for
the alleged human rights abuses she
committed while she was in office when
over 20 people were killed in protests
we are asking for justice for the
children that are orphans for the
mothers who lost their children for the
wives who lost their husbands we want
justice and for that woman to remain in
prison
for now the former president is only
being tried for how she made it to power
anya's daughter has been campaigning for
her mother's release
anya sent her a letter from prison
saying she's going on a hunger strike
because she has no guarantees that her
trial will be impartial
in 2019 evil morales committed fraud in
the elections evo morales resigned and
left the country leaving the country
empty he wanted to generate chaos and a
civil war and after the vice president
resigned and everybody else from his
party my mother was brave enough and the
next in line and that's why she's being
judged anna's lawyers managed to
postpone the trial alleging the judgment
of the former president should be in
person and not virtually
her trial has also raised concerns
internationally on whether anyas and
members of her administration are
victims of political persecution
the trial has opened old wounds in
bolivia and increases the polarization
that has divided this andean nation for
years
teresa al jazeera